[Music]
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
video is sponsored by skillshare and
we're going to be discussing
khloe kardashian's very controversial
reality weight loss tv show revenge body
now if you haven't heard of revenge body
it has created
quite the stir in the media not only for
its problematic title
but also for its unsustainable weight
loss methods
and general problematic messaging around
weight loss
but before we get too far into things i
want to chat about
what i've been learning through my
skillshare membership while of course
social distancing at home if you haven't
heard of skillshare
they are an online learning community
with a wide range of
amazing creative classes for exploring
new skills
developing interests and getting lost in
your own creativity
i think a lot of us are dealing with a
lot of extra stress
and anxiety over the future right now
and i also know
that a lot of people might be thinking
about new ways to learn some
new exciting skills and diversify their
careers
so i've been taking a course called diy
product photography
by mango street lab these lessons are
great for helping me
up my food photography game focusing on
lighting
location styling and concepts so whether
you are bored
you need some extra self-care or you
want to join a
creative community while in isolation
skillshare is a great resource
during these times and beyond and to the
first
1000 people to click the link they will
get a free trial of skillshare's premium
membership
and after that it's only around 10 a
month
now before we get into our video of
course you can check out my disclaimer
here on the screen so feel free to pause
this video to read it
or you can check it out in the
description below also a huge trigger
warning here folks
if you have battled or are battling
disordered eating
please feel free to skip this one
also don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that little bell so
that you never miss out
all right so let's just watch a little
quick introductory
clip i'm khloe kardashian growing up
people called me the fat funny sister
until one day i started working out
eating right and putting myself first
and you know what i've never felt better
now i'm helping others transform by
hooking them up with my favorite
hollywood trainers
and glam experts to turn their lives
around and shut down the shamers
because a great body is the best revenge
yikes uh her words folks
not mine so the concept of revenge body
if you
didn't quite grasp it there was inspired
by khloe kardashian's own
personal weight loss journey and
post-divorce revenge body
she claims that her body transformation
not only allowed her to feel
better than ever but it was also a way
to
fight back against body shamers in the
media who
always identified her as the funny fat
sisters of the kardashian clan
now i can fully appreciate that that was
not easy especially in hollywood
but chloe uses her personal experience
as the backdrop
of the show to really encourage
participants to lose weight in a way to
gain revenge on their haters
so yeah she basically just took the
premise of every 90s teen movie
and threw in some adult life challenges
like infertility infidelity
and divorce as for how participants
enact
said revenge the answer is very simple
they are paired up with celebrity
trainers doctors nutritionists
glam experts dermatologists dentists
psychic mediums
you name it and after following a strict
diet and workout plan for 12 weeks
they confront the victim of their
revenge at their big reveal party
sounds pretty straightforward totally
realistic and sustainable
right well now that you know the basics
of the show
let's get into the nitty-gritty and
discuss my
top reasons why i feel the show needs to
go
reason number one weight loss is
prescribed for
all the wrong reasons now let's be real
the majority of individuals who seek
weight loss
usually do it either for health or
aesthetic reasons
both of which are totally valid goals
and one in my opinion is not more worthy
of pursuit
than the other i don't think it's
productive to discriminate against
people who have aesthetic goals for
themselves
if that is what brings them joy however
this show encourages weight loss for the
purpose of revenge
against somebody else because in the
words of khloe kardashian
the great body is the best revenge and
while the term
revenge body may sound empowering it can
actually be
very problematic and harmful for one's
relationship with their body
not only does it imply that you must
alter your physical appearance to
essentially
manipulate somebody who has hurt you by
making them feel badly
but you are also changing your body for
somebody
else rather than for your own health and
wellness goals
research has also shown that behaviors
that are rooted in revenge and seeking
punishment towards someone else
can very easily lead to obsession
meaning that a revenge based
workout plan or diet that is externally
motivated
can easily become obsessive and
potentially even disorderly
it also feeds into the idea that our
bodies are the best form of currency to
receive
love validation and respect from others
rather than focusing on more important
things
like how we treat the people around us
as well as the self
love and care and validation that we
provide towards ourselves
luckily some participants of the show
tend to have a realization
somewhere along the way that their
weight loss journey should be
for their own sake rather than for
outside justification
and approval however despite these
realizations
the underlying messaging of the show
perpetuates the idea that one must
become more physically desirable
in order to be accepted and win
not only that but by focusing
exclusively on weight loss to appease
somebody else
the show totally misses an opportunity
to teach
really important lessons about self-love
body kindness and acceptance
all of which are really really important
practices
for participants to embrace long term
now moving on to reason number two the
show
tends to focus too much on weight and
not
overall health this is where i get a
little riled up
so chloe preaches that body
transformations are not about the amount
of weight lost
but rather how you feel in your mind
body and soul
now i wholeheartedly believe that
exercise and movement
should not only feel good physically
regardless of weight loss
but it can also help provide both
emotional
and mental benefits which are just
equally nourishing
so i can more or less get on the same
page with chloe when it comes to this
belief
but that is pretty much where it ends
let's take a look you're eating a bag of
junk food
i put three in my mouth right now
because i was starving
right now because i check in with
everyone you're the one who's lost the
least amount of weight
on a program like this you should be up
a good solid
six pounds of muscle already and down at
least 12 or 15 pounds on that scale
and we are less than half of that oh
lord this is horrible
have you been really honest in your food
journal
no but um you know i thought by not
writing things down on my paper
oh he wouldn't find out he write down
the paper so you know but he's going to
find out from your blood work anyway so
i would not write things down but
the proof is in your blood it can't lie
i really do think that i'm eating good
besides the potato
and like the rice and the refried beans
we're intervening now because there's
still time to flip this around
you have the best of the best at your
fingertips take advantage of it
it's only a few weeks and it will change
your life forever
and if i don't see numbers a change in
you
then i'm just gonna have to drop you and
get somebody new
this is inhumane
so despite chloe's supposed holistic
beliefs around weight loss
participants are viciously picked apart
and pressured to lose more weight
they're even threatened to be dropped
from the show if weight loss is not
achieved
in addition when weight loss is deemed
unsuccessful or inadequate
it is essentially chalked up to a lack
of willpower
rather than looking at the myriad of
reasons why
somebody may struggle to reach their
weight loss goals like
genetics age stress medications and
underlying health conditions
not to mention the fact that often these
goals are
pretty ambitious and extreme this
mentality around weight loss being a
strict
numbers game based on willpower alone
perpetuates the false message that
achieving a good body
is the only answer to life's problems
regardless of the cost
and we know that weight loss or being in
a smaller body
is not necessarily an indicator of
health
research has shown that individuals of
normal weight
can be metabolically unfit while
overweight people
can be just as easily metabolically
healthy
weight and health are correlated in some
cases of course
but not causation by any means however
from what i've seen of the show
i don't think that achieving health is
necessarily as much of a priority anyway
as it is just to make somebody's body
smaller
and the methods to achieve smaller
bodies among participants
are pretty effing messed up for example
participants are expected to work out
five to seven days a week for up to two
hours
and sometimes multiple times a day and
while this workout routine
may arguably work for experienced
athletes and routine gym goers
for participants of the show this is
like going
from zero to a hundred
it's honestly just unsafe
don't believe me just like watch this
work come on
two go thank you i need that
let it out all right it ain't supposed
to be in there
let me tell you how important this is to
me i'm sitting here watching you throw
up i can't even look at people do that
he's not the first person i've trained
that came the first day and threw up
now you got to dig deep for real because
we got a lot we got a long way to go
having a solid workout does not need to
mean making yourself
throw up or even worse risking
serious injury like i said i am totally
all for aesthetic goals if that is what
brings a person joy
but i do not believe that achieving a
hot body or revenge body
should ever be prioritized above
somebody's physical
and emotional health and by following
this extreme and like downright
torturous
workout method it's really not
surprising that participants
generally lose up to like five pounds a
week
which is significantly higher than the
recommended one to two pounds a week
that is generally considered healthy and
sustainable for weight loss
with that said i really wish we were
seeing more emphasis on improving
healthy behaviors in a sustainable way
and less emphasis on making participants
feel like straight up
crap in order to achieve some kind of
shock
value at the reveal party for the sake
of good tv
so reason number three this show needs
to go is really that it does not
adequately address the root cause
of their weight gain and emotional
eating a lot of the participants on
revenge body identify themselves as
emotional eaters however the show just
does not
do enough to support or teach
participants
how to cope with their emotions without
using food
so for example when one participant
acknowledged
clearly that they have emotional issues
with food
i don't feel they were adequately
addressed by a professional therapy team
as they really should have
let's take a look after my parents
passed away i gained
probably like 15 or 20 pounds but i've
been an athlete in my entire life
so i like lost it and i got back into
good shape for my freshman year of
college at ucla
you know i was enjoying everything about
my life at school
and then i was
raped since then i gained close to 70
pounds
[Music]
and i'm kind of haunted by it hate is
like drinking poison and hoping the
other person dies
in order to get past it to stop with the
eating
you have to forgive okay so following
some
obvious trauma in her life this
participant named jill
explicitly told her nutritionist that
she desired a
healthy relationship with food and in
response to this
the nutritionist suggested that the only
solution to her emotional eating
and to encourage weight loss was for her
to forgive her
sexual assaulter now while this may or
may not be a valid contributor to this
person's relationship with food and may
or may not be part of healing
i don't know i'm not a therapist i would
hope
that if somebody was struggling with
trauma to the extent
where it was causing them to use food
exclusively to cope
that they would speak to a qualified
therapist to really help them
unpack and process this in a healthy way
but instead they're essentially being
told that being physically desirable
through extreme weight loss
and restriction is all that they need to
be happy
which can actually further exacerbate an
unhealthy relationship with food
and body not to mention this
recommendation feels
really out of scope for a nutrition
professional
myself included never mind an
unregulated professional
like a nutritionist and that brings me
to reason number four
this 12-week intensive weight loss
program that they are prescribing
is likely really unsustainable in the
long run
as i mentioned previously participants
of the show have access to
a plethora of professional support and
resources
during their 12-week stint on the show
so including
trainers doctors gym memberships
meal services nutritionists the full
gamut
while these resources could certainly
help expedite their weight loss albeit
maybe
not such a healthy way like we discussed
as soon as the filming
ends access to these resources also
comes to an end
and i mean sure it might be possible for
participants to keep
up the momentum of their intensive
program
assuming they want to quit their job and
put the bill for gym memberships and
nutritionists and trainers and meal
plans
but the research tells us that
sustaining significant weight loss
through
extreme dieting and exercise is
not an easy feat especially when it's
done
so rapidly quick a good example of this
is the research done on another popular
weight loss reality tv show
the biggest loser which let's be real is
really the
og in dumpster fire diet shows so in the
research on the biggest loser
researchers followed up with
participants of the show six years later
and found that their fullness hormone
leptin decreased
while their metabolic rate had also
significantly slowed down
the result was that while they
anticipated the resting metabolic rate
would be lower
at a lower body weight it had actually
declined an
additional 500 calories on top of this
that right there especially in
combination with silenced fullness
signals
makes it literally impossible to keep
weight off so it's really not surprising
that they would put the weight back
on and while i don't have any long-term
studies on chloe's
shows participants i would put money on
the fact that
they would gain it back too one of my
biggest issues with extreme weight loss
reality tv shows like the biggest loser
and revenge body is that they feed into
this idea
that weight gain and weight loss is
exclusively within the control
of the individual they also imply that
the only way that you can achieve
health and acceptance in society is by
controlling your weight
finally they tend to perpetuate societal
weight bias
by depicting weight gain as bad and
requiring modification
while always showing weight loss as
being good and something that we should
all
aspire to achieve in order to be happy
or in this case
get revenge and that is even more
cringe-worthy for reasons that i've
already expressed a minute ago
so even though the interventions and
weight loss methods implemented
on the show are completely unsustainable
and inaccessible for the majority of
people who are watching at home
if weight loss is not achieved or
maintained
participants are immediately deemed a
failure
and i really worry how the general
population will interpret that
about their own inability to have
similar success
which brings me to reason number five
contestants are given nutrition advice
from
non-nutrition professionals uh
you know i have to comment on this
so i did allude to this earlier in
reference to the scope of a nutritionist
versus
a therapist or psychologist but i want
to comment on it specifically
related to nutrition since that is my
field and it's my expertise
now even though the show's emphasis
seems to be on an extreme
exercise regime as the weight loss
method participants
also receive individualized meal plans
and diet advice
from people who are definitely not
registered dietitians
based on the research while there were
very few trainers with some
sort of nutrition certification the
majority actually held
no credentials and none of them were
registered dietitians
even if i didn't go looking for this
information for the purpose of this
review
i would know that no rds were consulted
for this show because
no rd would prescribe an all liquid diet
for weight loss
and call it safe and sustainable
let me show you what i mean this is
phase one
is five days you're gonna have a
smoothie for breakfast
a smoothie for lunch and a smoothie for
dinner and a crunchy snack between each
first five days you're gonna drop a lot
of weight you're always gonna be full
and it's not gonna be a thousand
calories it's going to be 400 calories
and it's going to have protein and fiber
and healthy fat and it's going to be
incredible
400 calories incredible
how is that safe or sustainable
how did that even make it past ethics
dietitians in contrast are held to
really high ethics standards
and use evidence to inform their
practice and recommendations i do not
know of any well-rounded literature
suggesting that an
all-liquid kind of juice cleanse diet is
a good
weight loss solution because yes you
will probably
lose weight drinking just 400 calories
worth of juice every day
but that weight loss is largely just
water weight
and you could not maintain that weight
loss momentum
for very long because you would never be
kept on a 400 calorie juice diet for
very long
i would hope at least clearly the
recommendations made from the show
are made for the sole purposes of
getting results
really really fast because obviously
rapid body transformations
make for better television but if you
surveyed all of my dietitian colleagues
i think we would all agree
that this is a highly unethical approach
to nutrition counseling
sensationalism over safety is never okay
which brings me to my last point and
it's only the last one because i'm
trying to be succinct
i legit could probably rant all day but
number six
the show promotes overly restrictive
diets
so not only are participants often
receiving dieting advice sometimes from
professionals that don't actually have a
whole lot of training
or authority in nutrition they also are
being advised to be
restrictive as f to reach their weight
loss goals
let's take a look rule of thumb
if there's more than five ingredients on
something you want to say no
this is like processed crap
really sugar is the devil it is
a fat that sugar is more addictive than
cocaine
ugh i hate this weight loss show trope
of trainer
throwing out participants food is so
insensitive to those experiencing
food security which often goes hand in
hand
with obesity it's also so holier than
thou of the trainer that i just
it honestly makes me sick to watch but
participants are
pretty much told to avoid every food in
the diet culture handbook
including gluten dairy alcohol processed
foods
toxic foods and sugar of course because
sugar
is the devil
i also already discussed the concept of
sugar addiction in detail so i'm going
to link
to that video here and also below but
once all their familiar foods are thrown
out into the bin
and a million new rules are imposed a
lot of participants are put on a
body reset where like i said they can
only drink smoothies three times a day
which according to their trainer is
a safe realistic and sustainable way to
lose
weight let's check it out what jessie
doesn't realize
is i'm giving her a safe realistic
sustainable way to lose weight and if
she doesn't appreciate this
goodbye that is pretty harsh
uh and telling someone like strictly
telling somebody
what they're going to eat not exactly
the
counseling skills that i was trained in
in school
but anyways besides the long laundry
list of foods to avoid and this whole
kind of
smoothie set up they have to start with
participants are mostly encouraged to
eat
whole foods that are grown in the ground
while i am totally all for a way
of eating that prioritizes whole foods
being
overly restrictive combined with an
intense exercise regime
can very easily leave someone feeling
physically and
emotionally deprived and if you're a
long-term viewer of abby's kitchen
you know where that's going to lead
after their 12-week stint
probably eating all the gluten dairy
alcohol processed foods
toxic foods and sugar and never wanting
to see another damp smoothie again
bottom line i'm going to give chloe the
benefit of the doubt here and assume
that she herself is coming from a
good place in wanting to improve the
lives of participants
of the show however i just don't think
that she's done her research to
really fully understand and grasp where
her well-meaned
efforts can lead participants into poor
states
of physical and emotional health while
weight loss can
absolutely be achieved in a sustainable
and healthy way
putting somebody into an extreme set of
circumstances for a limited period of
time
all for the purpose of revenge
is just a recipe for disaster
not to mention it sends all the wrong
messages to vulnerable viewers about how
weight loss
should look why it should be attempted
and
how it should be achieved so on that
note
this dietitian absolutely thinks that
this show
should be boycotted and cancelled
so folks that is all for today's video
thank you again to skillshare for
sponsoring this video
if you liked it be sure to give it the
thumbs up subscribe to the channel
and i will see you next time on abby's
kitchen bye
[Music]
you